okay whoa why don't we go ahead and get
going welcome to our Thursday research
conference and in addition to being here
in person there might be people out
there watching it and if you're watching
it since all of our high-powered faculty
are sitting way in the back it may seem
like there's few people here but dr.
McQueen he's gonna tweet a picture to
show that there is indeed a good
audience here anyways welcome and I'm
happy to introduce today dr. Stephen woo
who's a member of our faculty and is
working on interesting project and it's
interesting beyond more the fact that
I'm one of his collaborators on the
project and he's going to talk about his
work in natural language processing and
information retrieval techniques applied
to patient data which is something new
for us at OHSU in terms of using real
live patient data for informatics
research that's so dr. Wu's an adjunct
assistant professor he also spent some
some time working locally for a company
called trap pet prior to being at OHSU
he was at the Mayo Clinic which as many
of you know has developed a lot of great
natural language processing tools over
the years including things that we're
using in this project and he has a PhD
in computer science from the University
of Minnesota Twin Cities and also a
bachelor's degree in electrical
engineering from Duke so let me turn it
over to Steven
all right thanks Bill can you guys hear
me all right cool
I really appreciate the introduction and
the opportunity to share some of this
research with you and so what I'm going
to be talking about today is patient
level search in EHR electronic health
record texts and using natural language
processing so the big picture here is
basically we're looking for groups of
patients we're searching for groups of
patients for example children under ten
years old with asthma now I have a room
of informaticians here right so what do
I need to know or what's right what
questions do I have or how would I
approach finding this cohort of patients
from electronic health records anybody
shout out any any thoughts that come to
your mind what is that age okay yeah
right age it's in it's in that query
anybody else okay I can't really hear
speak up wait diagnosis codes okay it's
one way to find them great anybody else
one more all right okay well I thought
of a couple of things when even when
you're just looking at children I mean
what population are these children from
right and just like someone mentioned
you got a filter based on age that's
typically a metadata filter if you're
getting stuff from a database but when
you're considering getting stuff from a
database which database are you talking
about how do you write that query how do
you subset the data in an appropriate
way these are all typical things that
we're gonna have to do if we're gonna do
informatics on a lot of data right and
that's before you even get to the
problem of asthma so someone mentioned
diagnosis codes back there if you're
looking for asthma you might consider
looking at icd-9 codes this is what we
billed for you've got asthma because you
paid us for it you know so unfortunately
my collaborator a clinical collaborator
did a study and did manual chart reviews
you can't see those numbers the
sensitivity is 30% the positive
predictive value is 57% for icd-9 codes
for this particular sample
so there's some evidence that for some
kinds of cohorts that you're going to
look for just a simple diagnosis code is
not going to is not the gonna serve you
very well right so okay icd-9 codes
might not work in every situation why
don't we look into clinical notes then
let's find the information in clinical
notes well once you open the up clinical
notes you have to say well what am I
looking for in clinical notes maybe I'm
looking for coughing and wheezing
whether they used inhaler whether they
had some positives tests or not that
kind of stuff right yadda yadda yadda
but even beyond that you have to
consider okay if they were coughing was
it at nighttime that's a different story
and oh by the way when we talk about
wheezing in the notes a lot of times
we're saying there's no rails or
wheezing so make sure you get that
negation in there right so there's a lot
of fine-grained semantic information
that's in the text that you need to be
able to figure out if you're going to
really make good use of the text right
so that's on one side of the spectrum
but at the other side of the spectrum
we're concerned on whether you
experience these symptoms over a course
of three or four weeks or more right so
that evidence is in different clinical
notes so basically what we're seeing
here is if we want to handle clinical
notes there's some additional challenges
and I believe that clinical notes are
important because because we are endowed
with human language faculties that that
actually communicate very well what
happened and it's very difficult to just
codify everything in a different way so
so we want to look at clinical notes but
some of the challenges that we're going
to face are granularity is this
granularity challenge right so you want
to get that fine-grained semantic
distinction but at the same time you
want to search and aggregate across the
whole patient level all of the documents
all the different kinds of notes and
data that we have for that kind of
patient right okay so this granular
there's this granularity challenge
so for that reason I'm going to
structure this talk in two sections
basically the first one is we're gonna
look at patient level cohort
identification and this is an
information retrieval or IR approach to
the problem of searching at the patient
level and then we're going to look at a
classification based way to look at this
at a similar problem and we'll actually
look more specifically at the problem of
how do you aggregate evidence from
single documents up to the patient level
and that's going to be in a
classification framework with hopeful
applicant applications back to the
information retrieval okay so let's
start with patient level cohort
identification the key assumption that
we're going to make right here is down
here at the bottom cohort identification
we're gonna cast it as an information
retrieval problem in other words we're
going to try to retrieve patients and
rank which patients match this cohort
the best okay so it's not obvious that
you would treat the order notification
but that's the approach we're taking and
so the problem setting is basically that
you have say you have n patients in a
population on the left here and for each
patient you have multiple records of EHR
data right we're going to take those
records index them in a standard
information retrieval kind of index and
inverted index and here where I'm
showing you just basically a text index
let's just index the notes from cell
and that in response to looking for this
cohort of asthma patients right response
to this cohort query we're going to try
to retrieve from that index documents
and then aggregate to patients which
patients match that cohort the best
right and we were going to produce from
there is a ranked list of patients that
you see coming out of the the right side
of that box and then with that with that
ranked list of patients we're going to
compare did my ranked list of patients
compare well with a manual chart review
if somebody did went through and read
each of the records and and said you
know this is actually a good fit for the
cohort or this is not a good fit for now
this stuff surrounding this task is
going to be two parts of a grant that I
have here with with Bill as my
collaborator where we are putting
together the evaluation framework we're
putting together some of the the stuff
around making this happen so we're gonna
be put with well actually we've pulled a
hundred thousand or hsn.you patients
from oaktree and gotten their electronic
medical records since the since the
implementation of EHRs here at OHSU it's
stored on a secure server and and then
we're going to be defining 50 cohorts
and finding basically manual chart
reviews relevance judgments whether
documents are a good match for these
cohorts and Tamre attendants who just
joined us is rather there talk to her
she's awesome we're going to be she's
going to be judging creating these
cohorts and judging them so that we have
a manual chart review to test our
automatic chart review which is
basically our search algorithms against
so this is in in process right now it's
it's not done it's part of the five-year
grant and so what we're using
preliminarily is the
medical records track data and this is
the text retrieval conference that's
what Trek stands for and actually bill
helps put together this corpus and Steve
bedrick I think also might have
presented on this recently but we have a
bunch of documents from Pittsburgh
University of Pittsburgh and there's
17,000 visits they had to break it at
the at the visit level and there's
multiple reports or documents per visit
and the idea is to retrieve visits that
are that are relevant to cohorts now
future work would be patients write this
they had to cut out division visit level
because of the identification and that
kind of stuff in fact in our local OHSU
corpus that I was just talking about it
will be protected health information and
so we'll be able to keep all those
linkages and look at actual whole
patients so in the tract medical records
track data we have 81 topics and they're
fairly simple text queries like patients
who have been treated for vascular
claudication surgically and there was
there were judgments that were done by
Bill and Steve and or the teams that
they put together manual chart reviews
to figure out whether documents and paid
visits were relevant to cohorts and
we're gonna compare our search
techniques against that okay so that's
the problem set up here's what we the
methods that we used to actually do the
search and the approach the general
approach is called language modeling and
information retrieval language modeling
ir and the baseline model is the query
likelihood model it's really simple
intuition basically you think I'm
looking for this particular document
here's the the words and phrases that I
think are likely in this document I'm
gonna stick those in my query and I'm
gonna write my query to find that
document right so that's the intuition
behind it if you have a document that
you're scoring for its relevance to a
query and then you're going to rank all
the documents and say the the best
scores are the most relevant to those
documents then query likelihood
does this it uses the probability of the
query given the document that's
basically just that intuition that I was
that I was describing earlier you
imagine the document and say given that
what's you know what's the likelihood
that I wrote this query okay what this
allows us to do is look at statistics
there was there are a lot of information
retrieval approaches that previously
used scores at very good approaches but
when we use statistics and castings in
the light of probabilities we're able to
make use of a lot of you know
statistical reasoning and modeling and
that kind of stuff and that's why we
call it statistical language modeling
and and that's why this is called the
language modeling information retrieval
approach to information retrieval okay
so there this query likelihood and
language modeling in general actually do
very well just out of broad broad
strokes but there are some weaknesses
for example the the terms might have to
course of granularity just like we were
describing earlier they might not get
that fine-grained semantic distinction
additionally they might be incomplete
there might be other terms that could
have supported what this term meant but
those are left out of a simple query and
there might be term dependence quite
likelihood doesn't actually even
consider if you had two terms what their
relationship with each other right they
just consider them as completely
separate searches so term dependence is
another thing so okay there are so I'm
going to go through an approach to
tackle each of these problems the first
one layered language models is something
that I introduced it's it's a
contribution that tries to tackle coarse
granularity mixtures of relevance models
and mark of random fields are well known
techniques and eventually I'm hoping to
combine all of these but what I'm going
to do is go through each of these
different techniques I'm going to show
you just a really broad view of the
methods behind it and then really just
the takeaways
from some of the results for each one of
those things and then look at some of
the future work that hopefully would
bring this together so okay we're
looking at again want to tackle the
problem of coarse granularity with
layered language models okay
so basically with a layered language
model you start with a text layer right
this is the the layer that's actually in
your electronic health records you look
at clinical notes and this is what you
read chief complaint severe cough and
fever cough started two days ago
no expectoration and when you take that
piece of text you can you can do
something beyond just looking at the
piece of text we run it through an
information extraction pipeline and in
actually there's there's a few of them
that I use med tagger see takes view
them it and that blue box there is named
entity recognition so out of that you're
going to get something like a concept
that you've identified actually be
discovery you're gonna find things like
whether something is negated
whether term is negated or not or you're
going to find the semantic group is this
an anatomical site or is this a sign or
symptom okay so once you run it through
that kind of a pipeline you can
basically annotate the text and say hey
I've got additional layers of
information here linguistic layers of
information and what this is what this
allows you to do is normalize for things
like negation and with with these
concepts you can normalize between
different different ways of saying the
same thing right so you've run this this
kind of algorithm you've produced some
output and basically what we're gonna
try to do is search over both the text
and those other kinds of output right so
so again what I'm saying is that a layer
a language layer is basically the output
of one of these steps in the natural
language processing or information
retrieval part sorry information
extraction pipeline and and
at each steps output you can you have
some output that you might be able to
use in retrieval and so this particular
equation would be considering texts and
concepts and attributes sort of
separately and then just combining them
together I call that the split layered
language model okay so that's this is
probably the simplest kind of layered
language model that you could have so
I'm going to give you some basic results
on a split layered language model if you
look over at the right this is mean
average precision those are the numbers
that your you're seeing here and just a
caution on some of the other charts I'm
going to show you a couple other numbers
as well those are not comparable between
the charts the numbers are comparable
within each of these tables so so
basically what we have here is the text
is this is your baseline number this is
the baseline query likelihood model
you're just looking at text you're just
considering the texts pieces separate
from each other you're not augmenting it
with anything you're not adding any
other layers and you get some kind of
performance now wet because we've built
because we've looked in the text and
found all these other layers of
information there's some ten there's
some temptation to say hey well if we
produced all these things from the text
can we use those instead of the text
you know maybe we've codified things
into this concept form and that can
actually replace the text so that's this
next line here that concept form and
what we're actually going to see is that
concepts cannot easily replace text
maybe if you did some additional work
but it's it's not a simple prospect to
just replace text and additionally if
you if you look at adding negation in
semantic groups and stuff like that to
the text that's that top box there that
also is harder it's it's not an
immediate thing for you to be able to
improve performance just by
saying oh now I'm I know the semantics
group so that's good extra information
right so it's not always more
information is better in that case I
believe it's because it's splitting the
space it's increasing the size of the
vocabulary and making your estimates of
term frequencies and stuff like that a
little less possible but I digress
another thing that you can see on these
on this chart is if you compare the
second and third line with the the
fourth line for throw the the fourth row
where you're combining both texts and
concepts in the same model is
statistically significantly
outperforming the single layers every
time so what we get is what we find is
basically that at least the text space
in this concept space these are
complementary representations right so
these are they have different kinds of
semantics or different amounts of
stamped semantics that are perhaps
overlapping but are complementary to
each other okay so these are split layer
language models now I'm going to look at
the problem of what if you have an
incomplete query and you want to do some
query expansion so this is work that I
did with an intern dong Qing Zhu from
University of Delaware and he so so the
way that I approached query expansion
was mixtures of relevance models okay so
the basic idea here is say you have n
collections you have you have your
pittsburgh natural language processing
corpus but maybe you have Wikipedia
articles as well or maybe you have a
large web corpus or something as well
maybe from those corpora we can find
relevant terms that are you know find
things that are related to the query
that I submitted the query that you know
the asthma patients that I was
interested in or the vascular
claudication patients that I was
interested in it so well the first thing
you do is you search from each of those
n collections and in each of those n
collections you
keep the top documents and within that
set of top documents you look at what
are the best terms in these top
documents and you keep em of those terms
from each of those collections and then
you wait the expansion terms you score
the original query you when you
originally did that query and got that
document list you have a score but then
you also mix in a score of well how
important is this particular expansion
possible expansion term within this
corpus right so so you mix in that kind
of a weight and then you combine the
scores from each collection then you
combine all of the terms across the
query and you get a final score now a
lot of people have done query expansion
and a lot of people have found mixed
results with query expansion I'd say the
key here the reason that this actually
turns out to be a very very helpful
empirically beneficial way to to help
information retrieval accuracy is
because of this weighting a lot of
people don't do the weighting in a
principled manner and here we're doing
waiting in the same probabilistic kind
of framework that we were talking about
earlier okay
so I'm going to jump to some results
here again and this test here is
basically showing what happens if I add
an expansion corpus so I was talking
about having n collections you I'm gonna
look for expansion terms in this
collection in that collection and
whatnot so if I go from looking for
things in one collection like the target
collection pit NLP and then I say hey
well I'm not just going to look in that
collection for expansion terms I'm going
to look in a large corpus of of clinical
notes and we we had a corpus of about 50
60 million patient records at Mayo that
we were using for this test so so pit so
when you look for expansion terms in
that additional corpus in addition to
two
the to the original corpus you are
improving performance every time there's
the change in your map score and the
p-value so you can see that it's
statistically significant even if you
had even if you had three other corpora
that you were doing query expansion
based on and you still added this one
corpus this Mayo Clinic corpus you
actually improved results regardless
okay so you might think that more data
is better especially more data that's in
your domain is better but that's not
necessarily the case this plot is a
learning curve and so on the x-axis here
you're seeing how many millions of
unique terms are exists in the corpus at
a particular point okay so what we're
gonna do is try to do query expansion
with this this proportion of the this 50
million record corpus at Mayo and this
proportion in this proportion and and
see how does that increase over time and
in fact what we find is that if you put
together this learning curve you find
that more data is not necessarily more
optimal you see that the results level
off and actually go down a little bit so
in fact not using the whole Mayo corpus
would have actually gotten us more
optimal performance with mixtures of
relevance models so that's a pretty
interesting result but overall this
technique of mixing relevance models
from multiple collections is very very
helpful okay all right I'm gonna look at
the third problem that we were talking
about oh we've got a question but I feel
like Mayo might be the good driver right
so did you do the opposite of this where
you have mayo and then you
yeah we actually have in in the jbi
article we have a comprehensive listing
of two corpora three corpora and four
corpora yeah so so what we do have the
the four corpora this this result down
here is actually the highest result that
we that we had in in the whole test but
we also did the power set of of things
no it's not
so clue web is this humongous collection
of web documents that is the that's the
largest it's like terabytes of data and
so yeah that's that's a really great
point size is not the greatest factor
perhaps the the similarity of domains is
possibly a greater factor if you look at
each of the each of these expansion
collections individually Mayo is the top
followed by pit NLP which is the target
collection itself so that's kind of
interesting because this large clinical
corpus outperformed the target
collection itself but they're in the
same domain so that's important and then
genomics was next and then clue up so
the least clue web was the most general
and and
helpful even despite its huge time
alright so let's move on to term
dependence and this is a way to handle
the problem of you know just considering
the work the terms in your query as a
bag of words where they're not connected
to each other and stuff like that and so
the query likelihood if you had patients
treated for vascular claudication
surgically you break it you know smoosh
it down into just three words and the
query likelihood model you're basically
independently searching for these three
things and combining this what the
Markov random fields way to look at term
dependence is there's two variants one
is sequential dependence where basically
you say hey I'm gonna look at this
phrase vascular claudication and
claudication surgery and and I'm also
going to consider if I don't really care
about their ordering of the terms that's
what's sequential dependence is going to
be and there's also a full dependence
model where on top of that you add the
relationship between things that are not
necessarily neighboring so you've got
all three terms at once you've got the
first term vascular and surgery the
third term at the same time so that's a
full dependence model so both of these
are Markov random field models and the
the graphs that you see here basically
embed the probabilistic assumptions that
are being made and when you implement
something like this it really turns out
to be something quite as simple as this
you're just basically quoting stuff and
giving them weights but the
probabilities that go behind the
weighting and all that kind of stuff are
our son of the genius behind term
dependencies and it's not my genius it's
let's learn craft but it's a really
great model and that's empirically true
as well this is these are learning
curves on the x-axis you have a
smoothing parameter I won't go into what
that is but
you can see really clearly here is on
the top the text MRF where mark of
random fields model is doing the best on
its own as a single layer right but
additionally if if as I'm trying to do
you want to combine other layers of
information the text MRF model this
Markov random field model also does the
best when you combine it with other
kinds of other other layers of
information so so basically we have here
a term dependency model that is is very
effective and so in previous work we've
combined the term dependence model with
the query expansion and stuff like that
there's going to be continued work in
bringing these things together so just
to give you a little bit more definition
on what I'm going to be working on in
this in this grant is I'm going to look
at the methods behind this this picture
we're going to be putting the going
through natural language processing to
add those additional layers labeled
content artifacts here additionally aim
to is going to be hopefully we're going
to add stuff that you're going to see in
the second half of this talk and so
hopefully we're the direction right now
that we're working on is combining
layers term dependence and query
expansion and then we'll look at this
relational and temporal kind of search
ok so what you mostly saw in this whole
section was how can we look and get into
that kind of fine-grained stuff and
bring it out and surface it so that we
can find patients using that kind of
information right what I'm going to look
at now is patient level temporal
aggregation and this is explicitly
looking at how do you aggregate data
that you got from one document versus
from another duck from other documents
for the same patient ok so let's look
again at that setting of pediatric
asthma that we started out with and
maybe it's not I think my dad's that's
not exactly less than 10 years but it's
it is children who have asthma now this
is a problem in from a clinical
perspective because there's delayed
diagnosis in 65 percent of cases with
three point three years median delay
according to one study and the
ramifications of this if if you have not
gotten a diagnosis of asthma then you
may be prevented from getting therapies
like an h1n1 vaccine or you may get
unnecessary treatment let's go here
instead you have to run a bunch of extra
tests so these this whole problem
setting is something that my
collaborator at Mayo Clinic has helped
me define and that I'm continuing to
work with in life so another interesting
thing about looking at asthma though is
because it's Carlock it's a chronic
disease we are interested also in
associating time attachment status not
only did they have asthma but when did
they get out so looking at the data here
in the problem setting the data that we
have is provided by my clinical
collaborator at Mayo
there's 112 patients fairly small sample
set but it's one that it worked with
before from Mayo Clinic and we had a
development set with very similar
characteristics and what we had was for
each of those patients we did manual
chart review using expert criteria so
these criteria had like main symptoms
they had how the time course you know
did these symptoms recur and then there
were some other indicators that were
additionally included and for each
patient doing manual chart reviews on
end documents okay by doing those manual
chart reviews we're producing a patient
level gold standard where you're able to
say does the patient have asthma or not
yes or no we're also producing an index
date and index data the technical term
that my collaborator uses yong-joon the
index date is the first date that a
patient could have been verified for
having asthma and we're able to infer
per incidence to satisfy that's what I
mean it's hopefully clearer on this plot
here in this timeline if you have if you
have a patient with asthma then each of
these X's along the line is an instance
it's like their document history or
their natural history so each time they
came in and he saw documents there's an
X there and we'll call that instances
that bar there is the index date that's
the date that this patient should have
been considered to have asthma and then
overall you have a something saying that
this patient does have that and those
the asterisks there mean that those are
quantities that we're going to estimate
so we need to estimate whether patient
has asthma and whether when that patient
got husband right so now if we consider
a different instance
so consider this that instance right
there that's before the patient what
should have been diagnosed for asthma
and so in that span that the asthma
statuses know and the index date was
none because you know they haven't
gotten asthma Yeah right makes sense
okay so so that's our data and the stuff
that we have and the stuff that we're
trying to estimate and the way that we
estimated is again through a natural
language processing algorithm
information retrieval producing 23
primary features for each document and
then we do a classification step using
machine learning algorithms decision
trees logistic regression we also have a
logic based rules version where we're
basically trying to write rules to
recreate the the way that they did the
manual chart review so and then you can
compare the the manual chart review
versus what we've produced both for the
accuracy the asthma status and for the
time
okay so now this is this is the
interesting stuff these are the methods
how can we combine these features over
time okay so again you have the
documents as exes and you have the index
date over there but here we're actually
going to be this shorter lines are
bronchodilators oh here I found this
feature I've discovered that base on my
NLP that there's bronchodilator use and
eve documents right how can i a great
this evidence to figure out whether i
and the or method the or algorithm is a
really the simplest algorithm possible
the first time that I see bronchodilator
uses and say hey that's asthma and
that's that's we can we'll wait that
against other features but it's
basically a unit step function right
okay another very very simple way to do
a gregarious to just a some data okay
every time that I've seen every time
that I've seen a an example of
bronchodilator use increment and count
up right and then try to determine at
any given point based on that counted
counted up number whether I have asthma
okay so those are two very simple
methods for determining for aggregating
evidence over time but there's also a
probabilistic way to do this
so I can't tell I have probabilities and
stuff like that so what I did was
estimate probability density functions
and the example that I have here is
estimating the index date probability
okay so you don't have to look too much
in detail at the equation but if you
look at this chart here basically this
the zero at time zero that's when you
observed a feature okay so let's say you
observed a feature of a methacholine
test at time zero and you move back some
number of days and see did could the
index date for asthma have been so so in
other words what we're seeing for this
methacholine test that that blue line
there
that the index date the date that
patients usually are actually found to
have asthma occurs before you actually
get the test right so it's my so this is
not necessarily a great predictive kind
of feature it's kind of like a response
response and already having had on the
other hand bronchospasms are kind of the
other side of the picture you see that
this is when the zero is when that
bronchospasm was found and over here you
see how likely is it that the index date
will appear so
so bronchospasms the majority of the
time the index date or the beginning of
asthma happens at or after start having
okay so using these probability density
functions I can put these onto each onto
each instance of finding a particular
future and I got it
so using that that exact probability
density that function that you saw
before estimated via kernel density
estimation and so if you can just
imagine like bronchodilator use the
curve for that here and then another of
the same curve that here the same curve
for that there and at any given point
you're adding up the evidence from each
of those curves okay and so what you see
in the blue the green line is the some
algorithm that we just saw but the
purple line here is the PDF i N which is
the index game probably
okay index date is the first date that a
patient could have been considered to
have asthma so that's so that's when in
chart review I'm reading this person's
chart they don't have asthma they don't
have asthma
oh they do have that that's today that's
the next day anything forward they are
an asthmatic person that based on manual
chart we do
so actually it's it's based on that
criteria those there's the week three
groups of criteria
the currents overtime and other factors
they're actually rigorously reviewing
the patient records and have their own
logic criteria for saying this is when a
patient has that that make sense
okay if there's a further questions we
can take it offline so this is the index
day probability and what you see it
doing in this characteristic is that it
says hey I've seen at each time that you
have bronchodilator use you're saying
hey I think I've seen something that's
really great evidence for asthma that I
should diagnose them today but then as
as you go on with other records that
don't have this kind of evidence that
assurance kind of fades away a little
bit goes down a little bit until you see
another example so that's what happens
happening with this the next state
probability but there's there's
something wrong with this model because
what if you just know do I have asthma
right now I don't really care if it's
Davidson the date that I should be done
how about pink right so that's what this
alternative probability density function
is I find it a different way won't
really go into detail on that equation
but basically it's saying it's not
saying given that I've seen this feature
do I have is today the date that I have
got asthma for instead I'm saying do I
have athlete's today and what that does
is kind of the opposite of the previous
for this particular feature
it basically says well you know I have
this I had bronchodilator news and even
though I don't see bronchodilator use
right now the likelihood that I'm gonna
eventually be shown to be asthmatic is
going to increase maybe another feature
will come in and trigger that that kind
of thing
so this is the positive ecstatic popular
so when we evaluate when I evaluated
these aggregation methods had to
consider different settings based on the
statuses of the patient so here in for
this particular patient if we consider
their whole patient history their whole
document history as one training sample
and say hey this patient has asthma
great that's one sample that's a single
status per patient present
ssp now on the other hand like we said
if we looked at one of these previous
instances that was a negative instance
for so perhaps you can look at a
multiple statuses for patient setting
and each of these kind of has a
different implication for when you're
testing the SSP setting if you're
testing on SSP that's kind of like
retrospective epidemiology right I'm
looking at these records at this point
in time I'm gonna look back into history
and say did they have a particular
disease that I was interested in and and
what we find is that the the results
here are mostly in this f1 column the f1
score and hires better we have the icd-9
codes giving a really low value of forty
percent these are the same numbers that
we saw at the beginning of the talk
basically precision and recall weighted
the harmonic mean and so forty percent
there with icd-9 codes but with any of
the aggregation methods and even with
the logic method we are getting better
accuracy and determining whether a
patient has asthma as a whole you know
it's looking at it as a retrospective
setting another thing to note on this
plot here are sorry on this table here
is that the sum
algorithm actually does really really
well that some algorithm it's just it's
just doing counts it's very simple but
it gets very promising performance and
it's actually if you there's a recent
article in jami'a by hip sockets talking
about sequence time and versus clock
time and the parameterizations of time
this is some basically allows you to
look at sequence time which is pretty
interesting
but anyways
unfortunately the or algorithm didn't do
very well which basically tells us that
if you're just flipping a switch that's
getting rid of a lot of information
right you're you're losing some
information that you could have used to
help make your decision in time of is
this patient asthmatic or not another
thing is that if you try to train on
multiple statuses per patient you're
kind of cheating because you have non
independent samples each patient is
basically in this in the training pool
many times and because those are not
independent samples the the performance
is fairly well now if we look at
multiple statuses per patient MSP then
this is sort of like a clinical decision
support setting I came into the clinic
today I had a document written about me
do I have asthma based on on this
information right do I have it today and
overall we see that this clinical
decision support is a slightly harder
setting because you're getting penalized
if you're early or you're late to your
diagnosis right the other thing that I
found very pleasing with these results
here is that the highest performance
that we have in this kind of clinical
decision support setting was with PE FST
and if you remember this particular
probabilistic method were explicitly
estimating the asthma status probability
given the features right so so this
method is is exactly designed for this
kind of a setting and it shows up in the
results so that's that's really nice and
we find again
that even though you're testing on
multiple statuses per patient training
on that is still too noisy because of
because of this non independence of the
samples and I mentioned that we can look
at not just the accuracy but we can also
look at the timing of we are also
estimating the timing of when the index
date was and these are all of the
different methods that were tested and a
holler timing fared if you see if you
see the bar on the right in in the
middle of the graph that's basically it
was dead-on within within a month on
either side of getting the index date
correct if you move to the left of
either of the plots then that's we
diagnosed asthma before it should have
been diagnosed and if it's after we
diagnosed it after it should have been
diagnosed so this top left plot is icd-9
codes again a lot of the a lot of the
instances were missed so that's that bar
on the right there and then if we look
at just a regular logic based method or
actually any of these methods they they
outperform in terms of timing they
outperform icd-9 codes really
interesting is this one PDF i n when we
directly in that estimate the index date
so again this probability distribution
was designed to find the right index
date right and so it actually does a
really good job of that and it
interesting Lee does not really have any
delayed diagnosis it has some jumping
the gun trying to diagnose asthma before
it actually happened but it doesn't have
any delayed diagnosis these are missed
cases over here on the right so there's
there's a lot of other interesting stuff
that we're that I'm looking at for
future we're looking at other time
points what about if there's remission
relapse and remission of asthma and what
about other chronic diseases and stuff
like that and then how can you embed all
those
stuff into an information retrieval
framework like the one that we were
talking about earlier and that would
basically be aim to of the the grant
that we're working on here
so in conclusion today what we've looked
at is this granularity issue with
looking at clinical text you've got to
get down into the fine-grained stuff
with NLP but you've also got to
aggregate to the large level with you
know maybe this temporal kind of
aggregation also other kinds of
aggregation in in the information
retrieval framework within information
retrieval methods we looked at layered
language models and saw that some layers
like concepts can improve performance
we're currently working on getting that
those various layers to work with query
expansion and term dependence and we're
also building that large resource here
at OHSU in order to evaluate all of
these methods and hopefully that
resource will eventually be something
that many others here at OHSU and many
of you perhaps will be able to leapfrog
off or springboard off of also we've
looked today at temporal aggregation
we've seen some interesting functions of
ways that you can aggregate data we've
seen that the clinical decision support
setting or you're looking at every step
of the way might be a little bit harder
than retrospective epidemiology you're
we saw that some of the results
reflected the way that the probability
distributions in the aggregation methods
were designed and there's current work
going on looking at things like
remission and relapse and other ways to
define these kinds of things
probabilistic lis okay so that's it for
today thank you
yeah thank you it's really interesting
um it looks to me like you tuned this to
try and basically get are you you're
looking for a math score is your
evaluation but I think if I was doing
some research I might want to maximize
my posit pretty good value because I
want to get a clean court how would I
change my your methods to do that yeah
so you're I guess you're mostly talking
about the temporal aggregation portion
here and so let's see I think so if
you're there are there are a lot of
cases where positive predictive value
might be more important so I think it's
fairly easy to just report like to train
a different metric you can just put it
in as yeah if if you're optimizing a
particular parameter you can just use
that as a metric instead of F score so
it shouldn't be an issue at all but it
is an interesting problem because there
are there are probably a lot of problems
within medical informatics that might be
more interested in precision anyone else
yeah
yeah so that that kind of estimation was
not necessary for these kinds of tests
the mark of random fields that that I
was using here are actually very simple
to implement and they basically end up
being like I said phrases with weights
on them so it's this particular method
we we probably won't even need to try
anything yeah I don't think it'll be
necessary for this put there there might
be other parts of this problem that we
can tackle with yeah so I just had a
question it's just super interesting and
try to follow most of it one of the
things I wonder is how do you deal with
the fact that you know your gold
standard comparator isn't so gold right
so often times you know what the
clinical diagnosis for these patient
says even if the physician has said it
has treated them appropriately there's
some estimates that you know and and
azzam is kind of a good poster child for
this maybe thirty percent of those
patients don't actually have asthma yeah
how do you how do you deal with that
yeah it's a it's a really hard problem
and I think we deal with it in terms of
when we're we're trying to train models
we deal with that by getting multiple
people to look at the same thing and
even if it's not perfect at least you
have you you have some set of data so
that you can characterize how different
are multiple people opinions about this
particular problem and then you that
enter annotator agreement that kind of
basically tells you this problem is this
hard it's you can really only expect
humans to get seventy percent similarity
so you can't really expect
a computer to do much better than that
right so that's that's one thing that I
would that has been done in order to
address that kind of a problem but it is
it is a fundamental kind of problem
because even if you're looking at asthma
or any of these other cohorts there's
going to be multiple criteria
recommendations you know comprehensive
review of the literature that have
different recommendations and stuff like
that and it's I think it's an open
problem but the the more not standards
but the the more attempts at defining
those things that we have the more that
we can kind of layer those things up and
use statistical methods to to overcome
that some of the noise that's inherent
in the problem just to elaborate on that
there there was it's probably about
maybe almost twenty years old now but
George rips at once in the early days of
NLP did a study and basically was able
to show the success of the NLP algorithm
by showing that its distance of
disagreement from multiple human users
and these were exit positions was
actually you know it was in that range
of errors so so to get absolute
agreement is almost impossible and
another thing that we know from
information retrieval systems evaluation
is that when you evaluate what when do
you evaluate systems using different
relevance judgments it for the most part
doesn't matter as long as you have a
decent set of judgments you can
substitute in different judgments and
the relative performance of systems will
will be the same so if a system does
good with one set of judgments it will
tend to do good with another so the
question is whether you want sort of
this kind of absolute answer which you
know George rip sex work showed is very
difficult you know versus a relative
answer
other questions
oh cool thank you